hey what's going on spice Lords this is
Sean Evans checking in from the hot ones
Museum of curiosities you know what that
means it's time once again for our end
of season fan QA we reached out on
Twitter Instagram Facebook YouTube and
ask you for your hard-hitting season six
hot ones questions but first a tour of
the museum and some of our new exhibits
we have chili chocolate and a whole line
of products from chili Klaus my favorite
the lucky bag you reach in there maybe
you pull out a spicy ball maybe it's a
super spicy ball maybe it's a ball so
spicy it'll send you to the hospital but
either way fun for the whole family we
have our wing tents sketch from Al Roker
Sean thanks for a hot time in the old
town Al Roker a wing 10 sketch I'll
treasure always and then not since Brett
Baker blessed us with the power rankings
have we been so touched by a gift from
fans but here this is very exciting it's
our new chicken wing board and it's made
by dream in the woods a couple of Air
Force guys who are huge hot ones fans
they sent us this Vic the Viking they
sent us new chicken boards I think
they're just like making me a nice
little thing for my apartment right now
really great dudes so shout out dream in
the woods if you need any woodworking
done
those are your guys alright what else do
we have
Oh some new hardware a lovey award for a
Russell Brand episode shout out to the
love you Ward's a webby what does this
say let's take a look 2018 People's
Voice Award winner
film and video best web personality and
host me and we have a shorty award but
while we were setting up the Museum of
curiosities a guy on our crew dropped it
broke it and cut his hand open five
stitches pray for AJ there's no more
shorty award in the Museum of
curiosities it's a it's a tough business
of curiosity so hopefully AJ makes it
we're worried about it all right
enough of that now it's time to get to
the meat and potatoes it's why you're
here it's the fan Q&A Chris shoenberger
hit me with the question big dog
thank you sir all right first things
first from Brandon coldly will you ever
do a fan competition to take the hot
ones challenge against Sean Evans well
we set the bar very high with our Brett
Baker episode that was a fan of had fans
eat the last dab right along with us and
wale at complex con we've done fan
trivia competitions and the rest believe
it or not there actually are some legal
hurdles defeating the wings of death to
pedestrians on the street but we are
trying to overcome that and find cool
ways to keep you guys connected with the
show but in the meantime our favorite
thing is when you guys make the videos
at home you get the sauces you get your
friends together do a hot ones challenge
of your own so please keep those coming
all right
next rank your top three favorite guests
of season six and why I think that the
three best episodes Michael Cera it's a
little bit more cerebral Michael Cera
doesn't do tons of media so that's
always fun
it kind of reminded me of the John Mayer
episode in that way I think
ISA Ray was a great episode really
balanced we're super proud of that one
and then Tom Segura super funny big
reactions just a no skip all the wings
are bangers good stories and then I want
to shout out three and that's Joelle
embiid I think that's the best athlete
interview that we've ever done rhett and
Link as much fun as we've had in the
studio since the Tyra Banks shoot and
then Al Roker shout out to the legend
all right did Tyra ever hook you up with
any of her model friends you know Tyra
kind of left me hanging on the model
friends but you know what cuffing season
is upon us spice Lords and maybe I can't
be running around with models all summer
you know maybe I got a take a step back
from that kind of life and that kind of
lifestyle for a second and focus on
what's important you know
is getting ready to shoot every episode
like crunching for a final exam so the
process is like this Chris Shum burger
and I have written every run of show
since we started hot ones and you'd
think at this point we'd have some
efficient system lined up but we don't
we divide up research we come up with
topics and every time we write the
interview day of and we're still in the
mode where we're throwing out ideas
throwing stuff at the wall seeing what
sticks and then all of a sudden we look
up at the clock and it's like an hour
and a half till Michael Cera is here
we're like maybe we should put some of
this down on paper so it's this mad
scramble to chisel out this run of show
and then we just sprint into the studio
do a shoulder roll in pop in the seat
the wings come down and just sitting at
the guests like oh yeah we've had this
planned out all along but it's just a
mad crazy scramble every single time if
you could live the life of any of your
guests for a day who would you be and
what would you do I think that bean
Joelle embiid and then just going to the
park and dunking on civilians I think
that would be like the most fun ever I
think that being Martin garrix and then
just being at some big open-air festival
and then just dropping the beat and
watching the place go bananas that would
be great and then being Sasha banks you
know SummerSlam wasn't that long ago it
would be nice to get up on the top rope
and hit someone with a flying elbow drop
but I'd switch places with just about
anybody at this point this one comes
from Alex and to Jane who is the hardest
person to research well different folks
are harder for different reasons but if
I'm thinking about just this season
Michael Cera was probably the toughest
to research because he's a tremendously
talented actor but no Twitter no
Instagram nothing to sink your teeth in
there and then he's a pretty private
person so you kind of just dig in for
what you can get local news stories
profiles scouring YouTube until you can
find this Pillsbury Doughboy commercial
for him for when he is a child actor so
you just have to dig deeper and deeper
and deeper for people like that can have
someone like Al Roker where it's just an
embarrassment of riches his career is so
long he's done so many things
you have maybe like 15 or 20 topics and
then trying to narrow it down for the
tent wings that's hard than its own
right too so different guests hard for
different reasons who would win in a
knife fight
Brett Baker Coolio now my instinct says
Coolio because Brett Baker is such a
sweetheart he's such a teddy bear but
Brett Baker has military experience and
when you look in his eyes you know that
that's a guy that's seen some things so
I think in the heat of the moment they
draw and Brett Baker knifes him up my
money is on Brett Baker if you weren't
doing hot ones what would you be doing
so always daydream about being a campus
cop I think I'd be a really good campus
cop just driving around in the cruiser
defusing situations breaking up fights
talking people down I think I'd be
really good at that I would not be
locking people up or handing out tickets
I'd be very live-and-let-live I'd be
very kids will be kids but I'd be one of
the all-time great campus cops that's
what I'd be doing I'd just be living a
simpler life as a campus cop how much
pressure is being applied to Gordon
Ramsay's camp we demand transparency on
the issue he's the number one most
wanted how many phone calls and emails
have been sent I'm happy to be
transparent about the Gordon Ramsay
situation we have gone through his
restaurants in Vegas we have gone
through Fox we have gone through
publicists and managers we have hit
every pillar of his empire we've had
first beefy staff run up to him face to
face at restaurant openings we've camped
outside AOL build there have been lots
of phone calls lots of emails
he's very elusive as it turns out and he
has about 40 shows so a very busy guy
but here's what I'd say to you you know
people always come up to me in airports
have you ever thought about getting
Gordon Ramsay on the show he would be
great I see in the comments all the time
where is Gordon Ramsay Here I am in the
season six hot one seat we demand
transparency Shawn when are you gonna
get Gordon Ramsay what are you doing
about it I would turn the table on you
what do you do it about it maybe you
could start some sort of viral camp
Kickstarter maybe he'd do it for a bag
let's see if we can get a hundred grand
together maybe spam his Instagram
comments with Chili Peppers and chicken
wings and fire blazing I don't know he's
a white whale he's just out there and
maybe you catch your white whale maybe
you don't but you always get in the boat
he's in the crosshairs the cannon is
pointed at him the net is pointed at him
the spear is pointed at him will we ever
catch him I don't know but that's the
situation
hey guys loved the show loads of fun was
wondering if you would consider having
more women on this show could not agree
with you more it's something that we
talk about in almost every meeting and
the challenge that we've had since we
started the show in a perfect world it
would be more balanced and yeah there
are reasons why some female celebrities
might not want to come on a YouTube show
and need 10 scorching hot chicken wings
but it's also something we can take
responsibility for we've made it a
priority in our booking and I would say
this to you rather than requesting
Gordon Ramsay for the hundredth time
give us five female guests that you'd
like to see on season seven hot ones and
put them in the comments you know this
is a show where we want to bring the
most interesting people on to take on
the wings of death it's a show for
everybody it's a show we want to talk to
everybody so yes it's time to widen that
scope and we can do better let's all do
better hit us with those suggestions
what's more important to you as the host
of this incredibly entertaining show a
good fun reaction from your guests or a
good answer to your question obviously
it's nice to balance those things super
entertaining to see some sort of big
meltdown and I laugh at the reactions
just like you laugh at the reactions but
we're an interview show first it really
is about the interview and you know what
if we don't approach these interviews
with a certain degree of thoughtfulness
then maybe a guest doesn't want to eat a
chicken wing with the bomb on it or hit
the last dab as they go through the hot
ones gauntlet so for us it's interview
first if we burn a celebrity out we're
never like oh yeah we burned them out
high five if it's a good interview
though the whole place is buzzing so
that's always what we're rooting for
that's always what the goal is
that's always what we're trying to do is
make a great interview if they spit in a
bucket that's just gravy can we
the behind-the-scenes guys and girls see
how wings are prepped and guests are
treated upon arrival you know if you're
a hot ones fan and you watch every
episode you can start to pick up these
Easter eggs with the behind-the-scenes
people you'll hear me yelling at Honda
off-camera or yelling at Steven
off-camera or Dom off-camera as Pusha T
once said about Al Roker if you know you
know in regards to Chris Schoenberger
and then it was a big season for camera
guy bill who of course became a star
when he ate a wing for Tyra Banks and
then this season getting roasted by Al
Roker called out by Michael Cera then
he's modeling our merch so who knows
what's next for Bill but I think the
sky's the limit all right well there you
have it
it's the season 6 fan Q&A in the books
if you shot us a question thank you very
much in the next coming weeks we're
going to have some surprise drops a hot
sauce reveal and at the top of October
our premiere for season 7 that's right
just a couple weeks off and then we're
gonna be on but we can't say goodbye to
season 6 without our one shining moment
look back on the season that was roll
the tape ok what's going on everybody
four first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even had our
wings I'm supposed to not have spicy
food these days they'll start getting
funny for me around here I think I like
spicy food I think you think I guess
we'll find out yeah I suppose that's a
kick up so that's hot sauce it's not
just sauce in Topsham
oh my god my tongue hurts this is too
much
hang on hang on does milk really help
how often do people partake in the
liquid
I judge you don't go to hammer on the
milk you will end up muscular can I get
some more water
cuz right you for the eighth-grade girls
to have the score right yes that's right
you've done your watch this is a good
deep dive yeah I like the way you talk
Naughty America or bangbros have known
bangbros Justin sounds better
how about when people call you daddy
does that make you feel good oh sweet
and if they means a D sometimes they say
daddy yeah Oh daddy needs cheesy bread I
almost threw up
oh that's horrible where's my gut pocket
what are we doing this is the last dab
we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing are you insane
you don't have to if you don't want to
say something like that it's a challenge
it's kind of like a backhanded way of
saying our usual and I don't but [ __ ] I
ain't no [ __ ] I don't say no to tears
easy there you go nope well I want its
last time try it out depending on what
happens I really like hey like you guys
too cheers Cheers
ready I'm ready all right let's do this
should have went to college you know
what's got a time-release thing doesn't
it it really sees that plate come on
sweating and crying and snotting and
mouth is like it's in here with my
[ __ ] wings I'm doing this [ __ ]
like hot things hold up that masterpiece
it's a sunshine with flames coming out
of his mouth thanks for introducing me
to this look at you you King crown on
the head from where I stand
that was amazing it was brilliant I'm
inspired kind of exhilarating Hey
thank you congratulations on season six
feeling good
wow that was really fun thank you for
having me I've got the respect Shawn
I've got the love of Bill and I've got
my wife going why the hell are you on
this
hot Ma'at million to 1 million three
that's pretty good form fill then you
get that cool shirt you didn't hear
ha ones merch it's available now I
thought you only wore Where's Waldo
shirts I used to wear where all their
shirts one
[Music]